dea
2012/02/13名古屋にでうんちを漏らすのは久しぶりだった
正確に言うと2年ぶりしかしスターバックスでうんちを漏らすのは初めてだったそう
人生初の伝わそそ穏やかな冬の朝だった僕が透明などをくぐるといらっしゃいませと
深緑のエイプのきた大学生ぽい女子ていいに言われ思わず
どうもと軽く頭を下げたそしてカウンターに行っていつもと同じよう
ホットティーお願いしますじゃあ
スペアミントでお願いしますそうですねじゃあ
グランディサイズでお願いしのと初めてその飲み物を注文するふりをしてお決まりの会
土打ちながらなんで淫夢サイズと言わないでグランディスサイズなんて言うんだろうと
思いつつ
千円札をアルミニウムのトレイに乗せたではブランデーサイズのホット
スペアミントになりますてぇ y にくい飲み物を渡しながら彼はいえ3岡部た僕は
もうず視線を逸らしてどうこうって言ってから安っぽいコーヒーの香りが漂う空気の中
を通り抜けこげ茶色のテーブルに向かって歩き始めた
おはようございます店内でお召し上がりですかと後ろから店員の元気な声が聞こえる
天井のスピーカーから
youtube で聞いたことがあるようなドローンしかねぇ
ふれか民族音楽みたいな曲が流れているほとんどのテーブルが30代と思われる女性で
埋まっている
特にでもあるようなスターバックスの風景僕は窓際のテーブル席に座って iphone
を取り出した
矢部アプリのセールスを確認すると思わず言葉が出た
新作マヨネーズが e book web サイトパブーでほちいだ
破っ興奮の甘えをもらってしまった
とその瞬間うんちが登場したクスクスをやっているだ
ポロっと出た
1週間以上を坂で時間を過ごしたらつい関西弁が口をついてもれてしまったかのように
びっくりするくらい
抵抗なくすんなりと矢部だから気づいた時はもう
をすすぎた運指はもうや僕の一部ではなかったのだ
暖かい塊がはっきりとパンツの中で独立を宣言していた
いらっしゃいませ
ないでお召し上がりですかありがたいことにバイクでスタッフに来た僕はハウスの上に
ユニクロのヒートテックリーバイスのジーンズそれから防水ウインターパンツをはいて
大丈夫飛び上がってからのミスターを取り出せない限りしばらく誰も気付かないます次
のお客様だ押さしかし気になる家の領域はどこまで広がったのだろう気になって仕方が
ね財布を取り出すふりをしつつ
僕は右て後ろのポケットに突っ込み徹底的にあたりを探った
生ぬるいとは
こういうことかそう思いながら指先を素早く鼻先に移した
あすいませんふと顔を上げた日本語できますか
声をかけてきたのは鮮やかなピンク色の p コートを着た隣家のそっくりさんだった
はいっ
少しを優雅な動作で彼女を募りの席に腰をかけてきたバニー何にた柔らかな香りがした
私今外国人の友達を作ろうとしてるの
座って良いかしら確信したが神様は道へ巣立っはいありがとう私に先
この情報総意とした手を出してきたもうもうず尻の筋肉に力を
を入れた
道元ですと言って何げなく手を伸ばしたら自分の指先が視界に入った瞬間 sat
引っ込めとどうしたの
あいやさっき蜂蜜をこぼしちゃってイサキは微笑んではちみつ漬け
僕はさらに尻に力を入れた好きですなんか可愛いねそうですか
笑っていると生ぬるい塊が足の領域を侵すのがわかった岬
は再び微笑んだ同件は名古屋で何してるの英会話た館一瞬古い校舎の男子トイレの臭い
が鼻を突いた僕はそっとして分はず iphone の電源ボットも3回もうした
いやぁまぁそんな感じでさっきから携帯で何見てるの私にもミスてにっこりと笑い
ながらそう言うと岬は片手を僕の肩に乗せある
またを乗り出してきた1秒にして僕はスターでできる自殺の方法の夏も思いついた
に設定お願いをやそれはとそのとき変な音がした誰でも思わず顔を上げて辺りを見回し
てしまいそうな本当に変な音空気がゆっくりと大きな風船から漏れるような
または風邪をひいた像が鼻をかむような音それが
ならだとわかった瞬間一生な付近にかくってありかなって考えて絶望に陥ったかその絵
では岬がさっと手を引っ込めて体を強張らせたそれに気付くと絶望はという間に
得も言われぬ甲府に生まれ変わった臭い罪を犯したのは
今度僕じゃなかったのは私の名前岬じゃない
床田中由佳日本一ありふれたのの絵を急に使い出した彼女はさっと立ち上がり
透明の道へと走り去ったその真っ赤の方が道の向こうに消えると僕は熱いスペアミント
を一口飲み
ゆっくりとトイレの方に向かって歩き始めた途中で私だけミスターんとこ種回す綺麗な
韓国人の5人組が頭をよぎり
僕は意味を殺した神様はド s じゃないドタバタ喜劇の演出家が
ん
[音楽]
me
rar